welcome back to las vegas now wynn's
newest kind of residency blue wire
studios is interviewing nfl star raiders
titan darren waller tomorrow here's how
you can get front row seats
jordan you're the head of the
partnership between blue wire and the
wind so what is blue wire what can
people expect uh blue wire is a podcast
network in this studio is a place where
people can come to record video audio
as you mentioned have some celebrities
athletes entertainers coming here and
have great conversations just a little
bit of something for everybody because
there's more than just sports there's
culture there's comedy coming there's a
whole thing you gotta go to
bluewirepods.com right correct the whole
list the full list of action going on
here so let's talk about obviously this
is las vegas yes
we got the raiders in town now you most
certainly do so it's only right that you
have some writers players inside the
studios getting interviewed what's the
darren waller interview coming up uh so
tomorrow we will have david meltzer
sitting down with darren waller and
michael phelps the olympian swimmer
right here uh to have a great
conversation i believe they will be here
from 11 o'clock to three o'clock you can
you know line up in you know right
outside the casino floor and peek in the
curtains will be up the lights will be
on
please come by check us out you get
front row seats to a darren waller
interview michael phelps interview and
so much more here at blue wire studio so
how can people tune in if they're not
able to come down uh
darren meltzer his uh his podcast will
be available on itunes spotify
i heart you name it all platforms it'll
be available all right well
congratulations on your launch
congratulations on your success all your
future success this is so cool in here
yeah i'm gonna come by and hang out more
often actually you should yeah i will go
ahead and get a las vegas now
i think we need you i think we need you
let's go why not
why not i am in all right and speaking
of darren waller i hear he has an album
dropping too yes he is a musician as
well so follow him on social media to
keep up with everything he's up to on
and off the field now let's send it to
jc he's outside ready to rev up some
engines of course jason